how many of you have heard of first
round capital you have cool a lot of you
guys so when we were starting our
company first round capital is a great
place a great place to turn to because
they do these really in-depth blog
articles about some of the problems that
their founders are going through and how
they've overcome them and it's an
incredible resource and basically by the
way if you don't know a first round is
there a EC fund with about a hundred
seventy million dollars in assets and
they fund early-stage startups and they
decided a couple years ago to go really
big with content because they wanted to
be a huge or they want to be a thought
leader in the VC and in the startup
space and so that's why they launched
their blog and since then they've kind
of exploded where they have something
like six or seven hundred thousand
people a month coming to their site
mostly entrepreneurs coming to learn
about how people have overcome this or
overcome that and it's become a really
fantastic resource and so we thought
it'd be a great idea to bring out
Camille who runs their blog it's their
only a team of two and I'll ask her a
couple questions and I've got my phone
here and so I've got a few questions
prepared but I know that you guys
probably do as well and so you can go
just go ahead and tweet a question and
use the hashtag con-con I don't use the
hashtag con-con so hashtag co and co n
and after about five or ten minutes I'll
start looking at my phone and we can
answer some of our questions so let's
give it up for Camille nice to see you
all
all right Camille I've already kind of
explained to people what first round is
and what you guys are doing but can you
give your your 30 second background of
of what the what the site is what the
blog is and what you do there sure
absolutely
um first round is a seed stage venture
capital fund we try to write the first
check to a lot of promising companies
out there were sector agnostic so it
really is across all sectors and about
four years ago we got big into content
with the first round review
that's when I joined and our whole
theory was that what was it that
founders really needed what is it that
they really wanted they wanted to be
able to go to coffee with the excellent
top thought leaders in this particular
industry who could tell them exactly
what they had done to get where they
were today so we were thought well how
can we have our founders go to coffee at
scale with this type of person we can
interview them and make that content
available on a large scale on our site
so that was what we were trying to do
and we've been lucky to have some
success so far and it's a team how about
you're a team of two we're a team of two
it's me and my colleague Sean Young yes
and we write all of the content in-house
ourselves which has been challenging but
a good experience and how many pieces of
content a week do you produce we do one
to two a week usually - and they're all
interview based so this is all us going
spending an hour with the people we're
featuring on the site I'm asking them
really in-depth questions and then
publishing what they say and what's the
length of each article average 3,000 to
4,000 words and these are not
transcripts of interviews it's literally
like reported like lots of additional
context woven in so I'm gonna ask you a
few questions about the length because
long-form is is pretty difficult one
thing that I've noticed as a theme of
today today's event is a process which I
want to learn about but actually first
can you explain you guys started in a
unique way can you explain to me what
your launch strategy was when you first
got it going yeah so we had dabbled a
little bit in content basically what
we're doing is first founders running a
lot of events like we had an event
called design + startup or we'd have an
amazing designer come and speak for like
20 minutes and then we would write an
article sort of based on what that
person had said and the more tactical
that talk was and the more tactical the
resulting article was the more audience
we would get so we thought okay people
really have an appetite for like this is
exactly how you do said thing and then
the longer that we ended up writing
about that stuff like literally the
amount of detail that we would include
the more popular those articles would
get so that's how we ended up with sort
of this long-form strategy and then when
we decided okay we are
go full-bore on this strategy we
actually ran a launch around first-round
review where we reached out to reporters
said you know this is a new type of
publication for VCS we got some coverage
there and then we also emailed about
30,000 people which was like everyone
that any of us had ever met haha we did
not exactly spam literally the language
we used was you will never hear from us
again but this is a very cool thing that
we think you'd be interested in please
sign up if the spirit moves you and we
ended up getting 8000 subscribers like
in that first week excellent yeah and
how many subscribers you have now we
have a hundred and thirty-five thousand
perfect it worked and the next question
that I wanted to talk about and I
actually see a couple people are
tweeting me about it
it's about freelancers and we had a
lively discussion about that and someone
asked about finding writers and finding
specifically copywriters and for
early-stage startups how there how can
they actually afford to get the content
that they think that they need so can
you tell me about why first-round
decided to invest in it how those what's
the ROI been and how you would recommend
other early-stage startups to do
something similar totally this is a
question I get all the time I end up
advising between like three and five of
our startups at any given time about
content and it's definitely a popular
question first rounds a little
non-traditional because we're not trying
to drive conversion necessarily our
content is all about brand awareness
well do you think this would work for a
conversion driven I think so I think
that if you have a content platform that
is high utility like I'm really strong I
strongly believe that if you're doing
branded content it has to be like deeply
emotional and by that I mean like people
are crying they are emailing their best
friend saying you have to see this piece
of content which is very hard to do or
it has to be extremely high utility
which is your audience really wants to
accomplish something and you are giving
them the information they need to
accomplish that if you are doing that
then I think that your brand is gonna
win with content okay and what about
launching a team like you have at us
company yeah I think in order to find
the right writers for you I'm a big I'm
a big advocate of bringing writers
in-house if you're serious about doing
content just because they can really
marinate in your culture really
understanding who your audience is on a
greater greater basis basically then
freelancer is necessary going to get
exposure to so if you do bring a team
in-house you definitely want to find
somebody who can write in your style
always give them an assignment during
the interview process that is actually
going to map to what it is you want them
to do see how that goes that would be my
top recommendation for finding someone
and when we started we used freelancers
and I've found that it does not work
very well I know a lot of people feel
that way it's actually really really
really hard to get freelancers because
it takes a long time to train them so
you guys do not use freelancers you have
you know you know that another person
and I imagine you might be hiring more
soon I'm not sure but you can you tell
me how you're able to train your new
folks yeah I would say that editing the
editing process is the easiest way to
teach somebody how to write in a
particular style it is very hard to
describe a voice to somebody like this
is the way we write and then you use a
bunch of adjectives that people will not
and be like yeah yeah fun frolic II okay
but what you need to do is sit down with
them after they've written something and
then take the time invest the energy and
going through line by line and talking
to them about the opportunities that
they might have had to then write more
on your voice and giving specific
examples so when Sean first joined me on
the review for the first three stories
he wrote we would sit down and like talk
about past examples of stories that I
had written why I thought that this
particular expression of an idea would
be more successful and now people say
that our writing styles are pretty
indistinguishable perfect so it worked
and so how long would you spend going
over each piece editing I think those
first three pieces we would spend like
two hours plus on going through them and
you would just literally sit right next
to them on your Google Docs or whatever
yeah and we would talk about every line
of the piece and now and then after that
happened we did an exercise where Sean
would edit
pieces and I would edit Sean's pieces
and see what each other had changed so
now I write like Sean just as much as
Sean writes like me that's crazy
cool and so let's go back to the the
long form bit because okay so 3,000
words yes for every article yeah that's
way different than how a lot of people
do things yeah I'd say that the vast
majority especially in technology is
very snackable sort of short items okay
what I mean in and so let's just assume
that I have no idea this is true but
let's say that you make fifty two
thousand dollars so that's $1,000 a week
so it's like each article is a thousand
dollars yeah it's a fare and then add in
although $52,000 isn't even is not
reasonable let's just go ahead and
double it for cost of employees so two
thousand dollars per article that's
incredibly expensive can you tell me how
how you're justifying this and why you
go the long form around gosh that is
another example in which I think first
round we've been very fortunate at first
round because they kind of give us free
reign to do a lot of what we want to do
and we don't have to produce ROI and
sort of the traditional way but we have
just found that the long form format
provides outsized value to the
audience's that we want to serve and
since that's really the mission of first
run to be in service of founders we
found that this is the best way to get
them the information that they need and
desire perfect
and so actually someone asked a question
I see okay someone asked a question that
I I didn't even think of and it's and
it's super interesting and it kind of
goes back to the freelancer stuff but
how many of you out here have tried
user-generated style content so a fair
bit so a lot of people think at least
that I think they think this that a
user-generated it's almost like it's
almost like you're cheating the system
because you're getting lots of free
stuff yeah right it's like well we've
got like millions of users there's only
a small percentage of people submit
stuff then you we've got free search
traffic right but typically I found it
typically doesn't work like that at
least some in our case it doesn't how
many people submit have tried to submit
work to you guys and why have you chose
not to accept it we have
but quite a few people submit work and
that includes like CEOs of major
companies saying like hey I wrote
something maybe it would be right for
first-round review are you interested we
are really committed to the style of the
articles that we have set on first-round
review which is to be very tactical
everything that we run has to be
actionable right away and so usually
we'll explain to the people who want to
submit things that you know we like to
write everything in-house in order to
conform to those particular standards I
think that user-generated content can
work but it has to work in particular
formats so especially if you are looking
for short form content and you can give
people enough specific parameters then
you can get submissions that will work
for you I have found that it is
incredibly difficult and this we've
really tried UGC also from like the
people who participate in our mentorship
programs or we have a workshop or
product managers in New York and these
are extremely smart people but a lot of
it requires a lot of editorial support
and speaking of getting tactical what I
like about first rounds website is that
you guys I mean it's beautiful to look
at very readable I mean that's a content
nerd in me speaking but you have in like
your pop-ups are very noticeable and
they actually aren't annoying thank you
the nicest thing you could have said
yeah that's my compliment can you tell
me about some of the so if you guys got
a first round first round calm you'll
you'll see the site and basically you
see all these like it's a it's basically
a big pop up that pop-ups when you like
scroll about halfway down it's pretty
engaging can you tell me about some of
the tools that you guys use on your site
because it seems like it's working
really well absolutely thank you for
saying that by the way because pop-ups
are a huge point of concern for me
readability is my number one priority
when it comes to anything that has to do
with first-round review and so anyone
telling me that they were going to put a
full-page pop up in the middle of
somebody's reading experience I think to
myself will that better be a very nice
pop-up so we use we rely on a service
called bounce exchange to serve our
email capture campaigns they do an
extremely nice job
and the real benefit that they provide
is that they'll do all the a/b testing
for you and then optimize tests along
the way so that you're always getting
the best possible what's that mean you
basically give them access to your
website yes we have given them access to
our website and our MailChimp account
and so they're constantly testing
language and then they'll use the
winning campaign and run a different
test on top and you don't touch it they
literally do everything they literally
do everything I have a monthly call with
them where we go through the winning
campaigns and I can kind of tell them
well I like this not that I like this
not that okay so you use balance
exchange what else the other tools that
I real and we use MailChimp for all of
our email campaigns it's very user
friendly I know it's not deeply
sophisticated but it works for us and
then also for my editorial calendar I'm
a massive massive fan of Trello for
editorial calendars so that's it only
those three things those three things
it's a pretty scrappy act over at first
round and the site's built on top of
WordPress actually we work with a
boutique development firm called mark
key if anyone out there is looking for
any sort of like custom built beautiful
content destination type stuff I highly
recommend them go to mark Eby they're
incredible team
what about posting to social we actually
do that all ourselves like straight on
the platforms literally TweetDeck is the
most sophisticated tool that we use for
social and after you've created this
3,000 word article which is pretty
awesome what are you guys doing after
that yeah it's a whole we have a whole
regimen after we push publish on
something we will send out an email on
MailChimp to our 130,000 subscribers and
those emails are very focused like just
go read this one article all the links
go to that one article really does
funnel a lot of people in that direction
and then we will publish across our
social media channels LinkedIn and
Twitter the most impactful for us so we
focus on those and we are constantly
remarketing our content so on the day
that we publish we'll probably promote
on Twitter three to five times and we'll
do it the day after as well and we will
use different pieces of content within
each post like the pull quotes or
bulleted lists and we will pull those
and put those on Twitter to give people
a sense of what they'll find we always
called that
I think I told you this the sawdust a
method I love that where you you invest
all this money and time into this one
big thing and now you just break it up
into smaller and smaller and smaller
pieces and try to capture value ya give
value in that way and honestly like
inspirational quotes or sound buy it's
like those really they catch fire on
Twitter more than anything else so the
more you have those in your content and
are able to put those on Twitter and
then have the link to the full posts or
to piggyback on how catchy that quote is
the more successful that will be and
another theme which we're kind of
talking about now that people have
talked about is the tools that they use
to get stuff done now similar to tools
what education services what pieces of
Education or resources do you use to
learn about how to become better at your
craft or to onboard and train your
people other than obviously editing yeah
I am constantly learning because I think
that we all work in an industry that is
moving extremely fast right now like
content is becoming something that
people are increasingly relying on and
there's all this new knowledge all the
time so for SEO you can't do better than
moz.com
if you read all of it literally going
back you will know everything there is
to know about SEO and then for social I
rely on the buffer blog I think they do
an incredible job over there and lastly
for anything to do with marketing
I like this website that not very many
people seem to have heard of called
marketing experiments calm where
literally they just showcase like
experiments that other people have run
and explain why a certain type of
strategy ended up winning which is
really helpful and speaking of that what
have you guys test it on first round
that has worked that you thought was
totally gonna fail or not make it any a
big not make a difference actually we
experimented recently with doing
compilations of old articles like we had
only run totally original content for
like three and a half years and then one
of my colleagues with my colleague Sean
who I told you about went on paternity
leave and left me to do this all by
myself and I thought gosh how am I going
to extend my own capacity I know I'll
aggregate my old content
into new content by creating lists of it
and I thought it was gonna do super
poorly and it turns out that some of
them have done better than actual
articles that I've written that
definitely was gonna do better I did not
predict that honestly I was like ooh
everyone's gonna know that I'm kind of
skimping here and it turned out to be a
winner
yeah what were the headlines Oh things
like six must-reads to scale yourself as
a manager that obviously don't work that
one I ended up getting shared like eight
thousand times which is like more than
most of the actual original content it
kind of made me angry we have this guy
who works with us and he like spent like
hours and hours and hours working on
this one thing and then this one long
article and then he wrote this other
article where this was before he worked
for us was like the amount of money
bands charge for a private performance
there's and that's literally it was a
headline and then just a photo and that
got a million views and like that's just
how it works so like typically I've
found the stuff that gets popular you
have no idea that it's gonna get popular
oh yeah there are definitely post where
I'm like this one is going to be amazing
and is gonna go viral and then it
totally flops and then some very
unassuming stuff has been totally
incredible yeah it always that's it
seems like that's a trend and so that's
why we're always just like just put it
out and you never know like we have an
article that just talks about like what
a billion dollars literally looks like
like a billion dollars in cash like
what's it look that yeah it's like
interesting quite like because it took
only like ten minutes to literally like
it literally took ten minutes to produce
you think that's that's a low value but
that's not always the case yeah that's
definitely true okay so Kathleen wants
to know when when you were building your
team out did your manager your boss give
you free rein to do whatever you want
and do you think that was actually the
right move gosh I'm a little bit biased
I think on the answer this question
I definitely got free rein it helps to
have a boss who is not a content
specialist or marketer at all I'm lucky
enough to report to one of the partners
at first round so he his expertise lies
elsewhere and whenever I come to him
with an
issue like this like oh I'm gonna hire a
teammate he's like well you're the
authority on this subject good luck with
that and I've actually really
appreciated that like he's a sounding
board when I need somebody who has an
outside perspective but for the most
part he really trusts my judgment which
has been nice so you you were trusted
because you know your your new guy
who worked for you he he wasn't the guy
who works through Sean he did not know
what he was doing necessarily he was and
he was new to the game he was new to the
game he's not a professional content
marketer yeah did you give him free rein
I did very soon after we did that
editorial exercise that I told you about
where we really got into the same rhythm
with our writing he inspired a lot of
trust the way that I found him was that
we posted on medium not just a
traditional job description but it
really was a JD as a story like this is
the type of person that I'm looking to
meet and this is how I hope our
relationship will go and Sean ended up
responding and writing well-crafted and
loving sort of note back to me that
really demonstrated how artful he was in
his writing and it was clear to me that
he was going to be capable of doing what
we needed to do and so it really only
took about three weeks from onboarding
him and editing three times you said and
then it was free Raina for that did you
help him select topics we definitely are
each other's brain trusts so even with
headlines we will bandy back and forth
some ideas we sit right next to each
other so when we are thinking of topics
we will gut check them with each other
so it is really really collaborative but
for the most part I really do trust his
judgment to go after things that he
thinks are going to be interesting
someone asked looks like Matt has asked
why or not why but how you do your
interviews and I know that you told me a
little bit about the process and it was
like pretty in-depth yeah the way that
we've sort of classified this is a it's
a three tier interview process to make
sure that we get to the level of
granular detail and depth that we want
which is really important for our
stories so the first tier is whenever
you ask anybody a question they're
likely to give you just a response you
know you ask them like oh hey how do you
do your social media and they're like
yeah we tweet two times
we post on Facebook one time a day etc
the second tier is then to be like well
what is the language that you use or how
do you do that some question that sort
of annotates or embroiders the answer
that they just gave you to the first
question and then once you have that you
ask them now give me an actual example
of you doing that and that's how you end
up getting to a lot of really good
proven material and how long does that
process take
we usually have interviews that are just
an hour long like we end up interviewing
people who are like the CTO of Instagram
or the CEO of Reddit so these people
don't have a lot of time so we will tell
them like it will be just one hour and
and we promise and we try to get extract
as much material as we possibly can in
that hour and did you say I don't think
I heard you say you don't let them
review we do you do yes but I would say
that the most impactful part of the
process in order to get quality content
was sharing the questions with them
beforehand so usually part of our
process is that we will do a pre call
with everybody where we actually decide
on the topic that we're gonna pursue
together in tandem and then based on
that I'll write a list of questions send
it back to them but before I shared the
questions with people the interviews
were not nearly as high-quality that
like changed the whole game for me okay
so we have a few more minutes so make
sure to tweet in your questions now oh
here's a good question what so like a
lot of a lot of the things that people
have talked today it's about tactics and
strategies and those and the tactics at
least change quite a bit right you've
been you used to work at VentureBeat I
did so you've been doing this for a
little while so you've seen a lot of
different cycles what has what
strategies have remained the same that
you do not think are gonna change for
another 10 years I think quality content
has pretty much meant the same thing
this whole time that content is either
useful or it is not it is either
well-written or it is not I don't think
the definition of good writing has
necessarily budged that much in a decade
how that content is packaged and how its
distributed I think is where the bulk of
the changes happen
and will continue to happen but in terms
of like this is something good that I
feel value has value for me and is
something I want to share that in itself
I think we all have like a good sense of
because we make those decisions for
ourselves all the time every day so DJ
asked a question that I didn't even
think about but we get it all the time
and I would love to hear your answer
why text and not video that's a great
question um so I've been doing content
for a while as Sam said as a journalist
and then I also ran content for a
nonprofit called Kiva where we were
packaging all kinds of stuff texts
photos videos from 68 countries around
the world and so I got to test a lot of
stuff side by side and video is an
enormous investment upfront and it
actually doesn't perform that well
because if you think about it like it's
not a passive form of communication like
people can't be really doing something
else while they're consuming it like
audio which I'm actually very interested
in so you would spend a lot of time
maybe spend a lot of money and get less
bang for your buck on video and that has
still been the case in my experience I
do think audio is very interesting text
I think is particularly useful for us
because we want people to be able to
refer back to it very easily when they
are facing the situation in which that
advice is relevant and therefore our
articles serve as sort of an evergreen
manual they're able to call back up we
could ask that all the time and an video
certainly serves a purpose but we're all
in on text at the moment because you
just kept you can capture a lot of value
for a very long time and when people
read out or people when they you many do
should at work you're normally reading
not watching like an eight-minute video
but you can like hide in eight-minute
read from your boss that's for sure yeah
exactly exactly right all tab yeah it's
easier to hide a read that it is a hide
an eight minute video yes okay last
question and this is a very specific
tactical one that I forget who the name
is Ethan ass and do you guys so a lot of
what a lot of publishers do is they pay
money to boost their posts on Facebook
is all of your stuff organic or do you
actually pay money you've been really
lucky to have it be all organic that
said for several of the startups that I
had
eyes especially those who want to drive
a lot of conversion with their content
and therefore need to run a lot of rapid
experiments in order to see what's gonna
work I highly advise paid content
because that allows you to drive enough
traffic to actually get meaningful
results to your tests but we've been
really lucky to have all organic from
the beginning perfect well I appreciate
you doing this and taking the time and
are you gonna be hanging out for a
little bit I think I will yes well well
oh and the very first question someone
asked that I didn't address yet but they
said that your dress looks awesome and
they wanted to know where you got it oh
my gosh thank you to whoever said that I
think it was Chris Kristina who asked
that Margaret sorry Margaret Margaret
that's so nice ModCloth there you go you
got your answer well huge thanks for
doing this thank you it's really an
honor to be here and thank you so much
[Applause]